جنوب صور جنوبي لبنان هذه هي الصور
الاوليه اذا كما نشاهد هناك دخان متصاعد
اذا من هذه المنطقه في جنوب لبنان في صور
اذا قرب صور اذا في جنوب لبنان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل اذا اعلن بدء
تنفيذ ضربات على الجنوب اللبناني
نعم وهذه هي المنطقه منطقه القليله هي
يعتقد بانها من المنطقه التي تم اطلاق
وابل من الصواريخ اليوم باتجاه اسرائيل
اطلاق وابل من الصواريخ اذا منها
باتجاه اسرائيل طبعا في عمليه نسبتها
اسرائيل الى نشط فلسطينيين قاموا باطلاق
هذه الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
اسرائيل بعدها قامت اسرائيل بشن سلسله من
الغارات على قطاع غزه اعقبها هدوء حذر في
قطاع غزه قبل ان ينقل مراسلنا في بدايه
هذه الساعه قبل حوالي 20 دقيقه اذا
معلومات عن سماع ذوي غارتين على الاقل في
جنوب لبنان وهذه الصور اذا وصلتنا للتو
لهذا القصف في جنوب لبنان هو بالقرب من
منطقه القليله في صور جنوب لبنان
اذا